hello everyone grandmaster varacobian
here we're
back for our lectures and i'm glad to be
back working with the chess club
and giving you all these lectures and
today we're going to take a look at my
games from america's
hybrid qualifier okay this is the
qualifier tournament
for the world cup and normally you have
to travel
to uh to play in this america's
qualifier but this this year they did it
online because of the covet
and i had a pretty good run in it and
came
extremely close to qualify so i was
unfortunately immediately on the tie
breaks with armageddon game but
uh i did win couple of interesting games
and the first game i want to show you
there are two games i'll be showing you
today and
we have two lectures today so we're
going to combine them and have one
long lecture so the first game i have
is the game against grand master
rodriguez okay so
one long lecture today guys instead of
two different lectures
okay so
i'm playing with the block pieces in
this game
and my opponent played e4
uh this is the playoff game in a round
number three
and my opponent is grandmaster rodriguez
villa andres
from uruguay i play e6 it's not a
surprise for you guys i played my
favorite french defense
in a tiebreak 10 minute game d4
d5
now he played e5 closing the center so
we have the advanced variation okay
c5 c3
knight c6 knight f3
and now we go queen b6
queen b6 putting pressure on d4 and
putting pressure on b2
and now there are a few different ways
white can play in this position he can
play bishop e2 or he can play
a3 or he can play the move that hit in
the game bishop d3
okay these are the options for him
bishop b2 bishop d3
or knight to a3 so you probably should
be three now i took
and of course you probably know this
trap you cannot take the pawn here on d4
if you take the pawn this is a trap he
takes back
queen takes and now bishop b5 check
picking up
the queen okay so that's why he cannot
do that
so after take take we play bishop d7
bishop d7 now trying to take on d4
trying to take the pawn on d4
and now if white decides that he doesn't
want to give up the pawn he plays bishop
c2
then i will simply play knight to b4 and
putting pressure
on c2
and if he tries to keep the bishop with
this move then i have queen a6 and then
knight d3 threat as well
so it's not gonna work very well
so he played castle
sacrificing the pawn i took knight takes
d4
and now he played knight bd2
now he played knight bd2
and normally we see white take knight
txd4
queen takes d4 knight e4 this is a
normal setup okay
and now we play for example
a6 queen e2
rook c8 putting pressure on a c file
so it's just a normal playable position
here this is what i was expecting guys
uh but my opponent played the knight bd2
and the move that i'm
i've seen this move before but i didn't
review it specifically
and since it's a 10 minute game i didn't
want to spend too much time
trying to figure out the most precise
idea so i just returned on c6 playing it
safe
and again welcome everybody to the
lectures glad to see you all here
and i'm watching the chat so if you have
some interesting questions just type in
there and i will answer them okay
and again we're gonna have two games
today i will show
one long lecture instead of just uh two
two different ones okay
now i played knight c6 retreating and
now he plays knight b3 activating his
knight
and now threatening to play bishop e3
bishop b3 trying to attack my queen
so i don't want um
to be under attack with bishop e3 so i
just go back here
queen to d8
now he played bishop f4
activating his bishop and as you can see
he's
uh ahead in development okay
he's a hand in development and now i
need to catch up because see my pieces
are not developed
so i need to do something to develop my
pieces okay
uh the queen recapture violation mark a
mark you could do that but
you know you lose a lot of temples
taking those pawns so that's why
sometimes it's dangerous
try to take taking too many pawns okay
yeah well you know retreating but with a
plan to go forward
and remember i am up upon guys i'm up
upon that's why i'm retreating
if i get my development in order then
i'll be i'll be okay
but believe me the game is going to get
very interesting knight c5
now he goes knight c5 trying to get
active now
putting pressure on b7 and putting
pressure on d7
now i need a good move here
now i need a good move here to activate
my pieces
so what do you think i should do here
to activate
my pawn is under attack on b7 it's a
very strong threat
i mean it takes a 96 mate so i cannot
allow him
to to do it this way so i have to try to
do something with this knight
guys where where should i put this
knight
to get some development get some
activities
of course i also have a move like bishop
c8 but this is just too much
you know pieces are going backwards okay
so that's why i don't want to do that so
we go knight g6
activating the knight putting pressure
here and now
threatening to take on c5
knight g6 the bishop is under attack and
the knight is as well
now he goes bishop g5
putting pressure on the queen
and now i need to get active
i need to get my queen active here
because i can also play bishop e7 but i
was
i was worried if i do this then maybe he
can take and
some knight d6 ideas so here i have to
do something with my queen here
so we need to find a good move here so
from here on i'm gonna ask you guys to
find the moves here okay
so you'll be in charge of finding the
moves here
okay
so queen b6
absolutely absolutely that's exactly
what i played guys queen b6
activating the the queen and attacking
that knight on c5
now he takes knight takes d7
king takes d7
rook e1
now he goes rook e1
uh we need to get some more development
guys development is the key
we still have that bishop on develop we
got the rook on develop
we got to get those guys developed here
so which
which piece we need to develop here to
attack to put pressure
bishop c5 absolutely developing the
bishop and doing it with the tempo
now f2 is under attack he has to he has
to do something because now we got the
bishop here attacking
of course you're not interested to take
any of these pawns never
because now he's going to take and then
your king is gonna get super weak
so this would be a suicide okay allowing
this so never take pawns like that okay
when your king is in the middle
so most important thing is to catch up
on the development now he goes queenie
too
rook h c8 now completing my development
now he plays h4
h4 trying to play
h5 here now he's trying to push the pawn
on a track to attack on the knight
now h6 absolutely questioning the bishop
and trying to force him to go back
he went back here bishop d2 and here i
decided that i want to start
slowly moving my king to safety king e8
king f8
okay
now he plays a3 he's threatening to play
b4 here he's trying to attack my bishop
and now what should i do here
he's starting to play b4 and
i made a okay move but i think there was
something even better than what i played
here
let's try to find the best move here not
the move that i played the best move
let's see some good suggestions knight
f4 cannot play knight f4 um
knight f4 we can't mark [ __ ] bishop is
here bishop will take us
bishop f4 so he's got the bishop
guarding this
a5 yeah that's what i played guys i
played a5 but then i
sort of regretted it because i created a
big hole on b5
and later on in the game i had to deal
with this bishop so yeah i played it but
here the better movie is actually
uh knight d4 is a better option here
which was suggested suggested by matthew
excellent knight d4 takes bishop takes
and exchanging and now putting pressure
on e5 and
if there is a check i can simply walk to
f8
okay
so that's the idea and now he goes here
i should have i should have played 94. i
mean the best
line is if he goes here just play a5
check and i can hide the king now on d8
this is very very comfortable for me
king is very safe despite not being
castled it's still very safe on the 8th
okay
so yeah i should have done this
definitely i played here and now he
plays okay c1
developing his rook i go knight d4
knight takes d4 bishop d4 now putting
pressure on e5
putting pressure on b2 lots of lots of
pressure
lots of lots of pressure now but i
realize i need to play knight d4 to do
it
so now he plays b4
now i took because otherwise he's going
to take on a5 so i wanted to take this
bishop b4 and here
i played a move that again guys this is
a playoffs game so this is a
10 minute plus the three second
increment type of game so it's not a
very long game so some of the decisions
are based on intuition that i'm making
here of course if i had
more time i would try to play every move
more precisely here
i should have just taken taken and take
the pawn on e5
there is a check but after 96 it seems
like black is just
doing really well here okay
i'm up two pounds and it doesn't look
like he has
that many strong threats here
but instead i played knight f4 thinking
that this is gonna give me some good
counter play but
he has a very nice idea bishop b5 check
first
i don't have any other squares but i
have to go to the eight
and now he goes queen f3
now he goes queen f3
so the question is what do i do now
after queen f3 it looks like i might
have walked into some trouble here
because now
my knight moves he's gonna take on f7
that looks
devastating so it looks
looks like a problematic
problematic situation here
what should i do here i mean
and if i take on b5 the problem is he
takes
and now my bishop is hanging and again
f7 is hanging on top of that so this is
going to be a problem
i can never lose the f7 pawn guys if i
lose the f7 pawn
i'm going to be in a very very big
trouble okay
so i cannot lose that
so i decided to take
liquidate some material and now
now what can we do
very very important moment here guys
what are we going to do now
this is a critical game and definitely
it would be very bad for me to lose this
because that's the first game of the
playoff
that will give my opponent lots of
confidence here
but luckily i you know in a difficult
position i calculated it and i tried to
find the best moves
knight d3 no we can't play knight d3
guys the bishop bishop will take back
uh queen b5 then he has queen f4
yeah well i didn't i didn't i didn't see
anything better here
i mean i didn't see anything better i
mean this doesn't work guys he just
takes
and yeah this just doesn't work here he
takes
and i don't have the 92 check if you
were wondering because the bishop can
take back
okay
so i took only five there is nothing
else i can see that will work for me and
now the bishop is saying and here my
opponent made a mistake
he had to play the move bishop f1
okay he had to play the move bishop f1
with idea to play g3 okay
bishop f1 with ida g3 to remove my
knight
okay so you have to do that but
he didn't do that he decided that you
know a bishop f1 is kind of a hard move
to play because your bishop is active
and you're thinking i should try to keep
the bishop there
so so now he played the logical looking
move a4
and here for a moment i thought i'm in
some trouble because
this h3 move is coming up
i even i even contemplated some ideas
like this rook c8
takes takes g3
and uh
something like queen d4 but
i mean this is this is not great for me
he can take
and you know white white is going to be
up a piece
i mean i can fight i have couple of
pawns for the piece but again
i'm only fighting for a joy in this
position
so after realizing that this is not
going to work and then suddenly
an idea came to my mind a very
strong idea and this idea completely
changes the evaluation from being really
difficult for me here to
a very nice advantage for me it it it
gives me lots of
initiative initiative and
my pieces become active
and my pieces become active
so what is the idea here his bishops are
so
strong his bishops are so strong guys it
would be so nice for us
to try to eliminate one of the bishops
and now i see some good answers sam
er samir if we go here the problem is he
takes
takes ng threesome here and now a knight
moves he's gonna take on f7
and it's gonna be a problem okay
and it's gonna take so that's why
we can't do that so we need to do
something
very very special here
rook takes a4 perfect rook takes f4
takes
i think uh when we suggested rook c8
when when do we suggest looks eight here
yeah yeah he can he has bishop e7 too
but then we taking e7 and
rook c8 i mean
probably white is better but i don't
want to play rook c8s anyway so we have
rooks
here takes and we take
he has to take because he doesn't have a
way to protect this guy
takes and we take now the bishop is
under attack okay
now let's let's let's count the material
so we have a better
understanding of what's going on okay
so right now i have
um knight
and three pawns basically knight and
three puns for
rook again the value of the rook is
five knight and three pounds we have six
so technically uh
technically we're up a pawn here six
verses
and the most importantly now we also
eliminated a lot of the the danger for
our
king okay there is still a little bit of
danger but most of the danger is
eliminated so he goes here
bishop d6
now he played queenie three attacking
the bishop
so the bishop is under attack so i went
bishop d6
just to defend now everything is under
control
and um i was expecting him to play
something like bishop
bishop b3 or something something like
that but anyway bishop d1
a little bit awkward looking move here
and here i
uh i played a very nice move very nice
move i played
uh but also i had a simpler idea as well
now my position is really really good
here
so let's think and try to find the best
continuation here guys
uh how many players will be in the world
cup um
from us
there are three three who qualified and
plus another seven maybe maybe ten
total so we'll probably have ten ten
players representing us
yeah d4 i agree with you d4 is a very
natural move now trying to give a check
now if if anywhere then we have queenie
one check and if he goes here
now we need to attack this queen this
queen is strong here so
how we can try to remove this queen i
saw the move d4 but i didn't look deeper
and i didn't look deeper to find this
this next move
this move is very strong f5 yes
questioning the queen and now queen has
to go away
so now we go check
check he goes here and now
you can check and give him eight next
move okay
so yeah this is very strong actually
much much simpler i just
in a position like this with the bishop
you have difficulties
finding these ideas because uh you would
think oh i'm weakening the light squares
so it's more difficult so now i played
here
but my move is very nice too but again i
should have just played d4
queen e4 and f5 and this would have been
perfect
okay
i played knight d3 as
a very nice move because i calculated if
it takes
what do we do guys if he takes what do
we do
what is my follow-up here
queen e1 well it's not a mate yet
because here's this
and now a very strong mobish page to a
deflection
a deflection okay takes
queen takes okay
and now the bishop is pinned and we're
going to take on f2
okay
so now
knight d3 he played rook a1
yeah if the king was only eight i agree
that's a very good point if the king was
on a light square
like here and here this wouldn't have
worked because he would have a discovery
check
but luckily it's not the king is on a
dark square here
it's not on its usual square now he
plays
rook a1 and uh just trying to step away
from this and
here i had something else prepared now
against this
something else i have here guys
block to play and win now
well queenie one check he takes
i don't know queenie one he just takes
we need to expose the position of
opponent's king
again i'm i'm a bit worried about d4
because he has queen e4 for example
so i'm a bit concerned about just
playing d4 like that
there are some rook a1 checks later on
too he can do so
we have to be a little bit careful
knight takes f2 correct yes
correct because now if he takes with the
queen
we go bishop c5 pinning and winning
okay so he has to take back with the
king
and bishop c5 pinning the sky and if it
takes
all right
so after i played here he started to
think but
uh it's a little too late now because
bishop c5 is coming out so for example
if he tries to move the bishop
bishop c5 attacking the queen
queen takes h4 and then we move the
knight
and we just try to give the mate
okay
now after spending about two minutes
realizing that position is just hopeless
he went for
rook to a4
now don't rush don't rush guys take your
time
you know we don't want to keep the game
complicated
just keep it simple now
we just want to keep it simple yep
knight takes d1
absolutely hitting the queen
now he doesn't have any checks here here
so he has to take
knight takes e3
and now i'm up too much material
he played a couple of more moves here
but it's it's not
uh that important now once i get this
it's two i have two pieces and too many
pawns
since this was a shorter time control he
just played down a little bit but
and at the end very nice he's got one
threat now to play
rook to be a check so we just play
f6 and king seven top seven from us
i think so i think yoga yogi yeah i
think uh we have the top seven from us
and then we have three other guys to
qualify so we'll have about 10
representatives okay we will have about
10
representatives in the upcoming world
cup next month okay
it's going to be in the beginning of uh
uh july 10th okay
july 10th in russia
okay all right
so so here my opponent went here
f6 once again just keep everything
protected
and here and i just play g5
and just continue pushing my opponent
resigned
because there is not much you can do
here all right i hope you guys enjoyed
this game and i was happy to play the
french
after after some time and i haven't
played any competitive chess
like serious tournament like this uh
since november
uh you know november of 2019 so it was
about
a little bit more than a year and a half
actually so it was uh
i was excited to be back and play you
know
try to play some good chess again all
right so i won this game
and then the following game i i was
winning as well but i
i took a draw and advanced to the final
so now we are i'm at the final and i
need to win this match
against grand master from argentina 2530
and i'm going to show you that game the
second game of that match
the heartbreak game
i didn't play very well in the first
game guys
i didn't play very well in the first
game and against grand master chrissa
26 25 30 video rating so i was i was
losing in the first game
but i got lucky he made some mistakes in
the rook end game and then i got some
chances
and eventually i held but i was losing
in the first game
so that was a good sign because
now i feel like okay i have a chance
with the white pieces
and this is a critical game if i win
this game i win my group and i qualify
to the world cup so a lot on the line
here
d4 knight f6
c4 g6 thank you i'm glad you're enjoying
the lectures yogi
knight c3 now d5
now he played the grunfeld defense this
is always a tough
opening to to crack and there's a tough
opening
to get an advantage so there's so many
different ways you can play but i
decided
i should just play classical it takes
take
e4 take sticks
bishop g7 so and
he played queen a5 he had another game
that he played castle here
he hit the game he castled and played
bishop g4
and uh you know
that game ended in a draw here but i had
some ideas there but now i play queen a5
now threatening to take take so i have
to go here
and i go roxy1 just to protect
and here there are different ways black
can continue he can play rook d8 he can
play knight c6
or you can play bishop uh
i didn't review this particular line
because i wasn't
expecting the queen a5 that much so i
didn't
remember like really fresh uh
how i had to play so i decided i will
just try to get out of the opening
and just get some kind of playable
position so
the main move here is d5 okay
if you're if you're wondering you should
play the move d5 here that's the main
move in this position
i play bishop e2
just developing and now let's say if he
plays knight c6
i was planning to just play d5 takes
g takes f here i can
play with f4 and c4 something like this
play this position but
um he played a very interesting move
knight d7
the very interesting move knight d7 and
i had to spend some time here because
i realize in a lot of these lines he
wants to go here
here and some knight c4 ideas too
so i had to do something here so for
example also i cannot just castle if
you're wondering why didn't just castle
because it takes
takes takes takes
and bishop takes pawn okay
so now i have to make a decision and if
i play the move
uh e5 the d5 then i think he might play
c4
there's a little bit of a problem taking
because he is hook fc8
putting pressure now here and since if i
was castled i would just move the bishop
but here now c3 is hanging too
so um there were some games played with
c4 and bishop d4 here played
recently there was a game of jeff
jeffrey strong
so maybe this is playable like this but
i i just wanted to get the bishop so i
played h3
takes and now very important moment here
guys
how should we take back here i know the
question may seem very
obvious but please think
please think so you can see the idea
because he does he does have an idea
that he wants to do here
how should i capture here what is the
correct
what is the correct way to capture
what is the correct way to capture
take with the pawn okay well let's take
a look taking with the bishop because
that might be the
the first question you know why not take
with the bishop
because if you think of the bishop he
plays queen b6
and now he's threatening a very annoying
annoying knight c4 he may
seem like wait a minute we can do
something about that don't we
but the question is what it's a
bishop e2 for example to stop him from
coming there
but then we run into this problem he
takes
takes takes we can't take back with the
bishop because we're dropping d4 so we
have to take back with the king
and now he goes here rook fd8
putting pressure on d4
now i play if i play e5 he just takes
so if he plays d5 just e6
breaking the center
yeah here black looks better i agree
with you because my king is stuck in the
middle of the board
and i don't have a good way to defend if
i get if i had my rook here i go k1 then
i'm clearly better
so it's amazing that one move makes
such a difference i probably can
equalize the game here somehow but again
i
wasn't interested in just trying to
equalize here
uh so unfortunately yet i don't have
anything
good here so that's why i had to take
back of the pawn
now he played e6 because e6 is
directly against the move d5 here okay
so six but the problem i have here now i
still cannot cancel
okay i still cannot cancel here
so i need to do something and this
something is
very very important okay guys this
something is very important so this is a
game
in the final second classical this is a
classical game so there is more time to
think and play this is a classical game
against
chrisa
very important moment here what move
should i play here guys
now how should i try today no bishop h6
doesn't
work if you never want to take on c5 if
you take on c5 he goes knight takes c5
it's not gonna look good
okay
now very special move here e5
i don't know if i then i'm worried about
that b6 knight d5
you know then his knight can get to d5
knight b6
95
now it's rook b1 here
that's a possibility it's a possibility
rook b1
but better i want to try to castle here
guys
you need to make a move that is going to
help me with castling problem
okay that's the problem i have i cannot
castle here
we need we need to do something to
prevent
you know so we need to do something so
we can defend our center
and get ready to castle so it took me
about 30 minutes to play this move
because i was calculating a lot of
things
uh but my opponent probably missed it
too because he started to think a lot
too
uh we can't play king f1 king f1 he
takes ryan
takes takes and then trade quinn's
and then d4 pawn is dropping
so we can't just move the
so you know and plus he wants to play
like rook fd8
rook fd8 and start putting more pressure
uh yeah i looked at that line but
rook c7 maybe just goes knight c5
the maximum i can achieve there is maybe
some kind of equality if i'm if i'm
lucky if i'm lucky there
some kind of equality
all right looks like we see the right
move here
rook g2 absolutely rook c2 absolutely
okay
protecting the queen and in case of the
captures now i can take back with the
rook
so nothing is stopping me now from
castling okay
uh why not castle i just mentioned this
mark if i castle
he takes got to take back with the pawn
here
and then he trades
and he picks up my central pawn okay
because i have to make a retreating move
with my bishop
so that's why i play rook c2 now he
plays knight b6
he's trying to get active
finally time to castle now he goes here
here
again i should just play a little bit
faster i keep spending some
time on moves that i shouldn't have so
what is the most natural and logical
move in this position that i should play
rook d1 is possible but then you're kind
of blocking your other rook
on f1 so i kind of want to have that
first round clear so i can move my rook
whenever i want to move i can move it to
d1 i can move it to any other squares
okay
what's the best move here which piece
now we need to bring into the game
group d1 rook d1 okay rook d1 is
definitely a move
okay rook d1 is definitely a move uh
but what else we can try to do
rook d1 is definitely a move but what
else we have here
thank you thank you chudir appreciate
the compliment
i don't want to play bishop h6 spider we
don't want to trade the bishop my only
advantage here is the pair of the
bishops
the only reason i have advantage is
these two bishops
if i trade the dark square bishop then i
will lose my pair of bishops okay
so in this position i don't want to
trade bishops i want to bring my rook
into the game
the rook on f1 it's not developed okay
so we need to figure out a good square
now for that rook
rook b1 perfect now we are putting
pressure to this knight this knight
cannot move easily we can take on b7 we
got some rook b5 ideas
coming up as well okay we got some nice
rp5 ideas coming up
now he plays
c takes d4 the critical line in this
position is this
if he plays rook fda completing the
development
uh i i actually can play this quiet move
king g2
which computer likes it says white is a
little bit better but in my calculation
i was going to try to get this in
attacking the rook and if he goes here i
go bishop b5
now getting some ideas on this rook the
bishops are very strong
and if he goes here for example we can
trap him now
with this okay look
getting trapped if he plays
if he plays here then it's possible we
can push
an attack okay
d5 so
this is what i was going to do oh king
g2 is good too because if it takes
we just take and the queen is hanging
tricks
i take and now we are defending this
so it's slightly very slightly better
for white here
but my opponent decided to take
i take back and now he spent a little
bit more time here he was trying to
consider
what to do here because when opponent
king is exposed
often times you think you can make a
move like queen h5 here
and try to have some control but
actually this one was just losing
we take takes and king g2
and the queen is completely out of place
and now i have ideas such as bishop g5
and f4 bishop g5 f4
simply trapping the queen okay
bishop g5 f4 and the queen cannot go
anywhere
okay
so he played uh
queen takes d2 exchange which is the
correct decision
and now we take now i kind of achieve a
type of position that i wanted it to get
against him from the get go
end game with two bishops with some good
center here
and zero zero losing chances and
uh good winning chances let's put it
this way but again here now we need to
pause and think because
you know i'm the one with little bit of
vulnerable center here
i do have two bishops but how do i
proceed in this position
okay how do i continue here because
it doesn't look that easy
now what's the plan here uh a4 was my
first choice two guys but the problem is
he just takes
a4 he just takes and i know you want to
go to b7 but
i think he can just play a5 there
and it's it's unclear okay
so a4
takes this a5
and now knight is landing on c3
and knight is landing on c3 and
some pressure okay so
that's why i didn't play that
so what's the plan here i like your plan
guys
h i like your a4a5 plum but we're gonna
need to prepare that somehow okay
we can't just uh go for it we need to
prepare it
move the king up one square uh bishop g5
we can
guys somebody said bishop g5 he will
just take on d4
again i want to play a4 how bad is
bishop b5
no it's the best that's what i played
mark
that's the best move bishop b5
activating the bishop
controlling a lot of squares and now
getting ready to play a4a5
getting ready to play a4 a5 to put
pressure
okay now he goes rox c7
a4 now threatening to play a5
okay
threatening to play a5 he goes here
knight to c8
so he's trying to regroup his forces and
here
uh i made a move that it's it's
important to play in this positions guys
you want to bring your king into the
game a little bit closer my king on g1
not doing anything so i kind of want
this king to be a little bit closer so i
played this move
to bring it the king in
now i also set up a little little trap
for him
so he played b6 which is the correct
move if he plays knight d6
why is this a mistake guys if he plays
96
why is this a mistake
i have a very strong idea now against
this move
now what to do d5 absolutely d5
yes now if he takes we can go rook takes
d5 and then
he's going to be in serious trouble with
this pin okay
uh and if he takes very take back with
the palm
and now we're threatening to play b6
okay
it's very hard to do anything now to
stop b6 so like for example if he takes
equal b6 hitting this guy
if it takes bishop takes taking the rook
on c7
okay
so and if he tries to play b6 himself
i take hitting the rook if he takes back
i take on d8
if he goes here
and i can just take
i mean i can even i can even take on f7
and play this position here i'm slightly
better here
because these two pawns are fixed
against one yes you can take here
like in g2 i can play i have basically
three on
two here this one pawn on b5 is fixing
the a7 and b6
so but he didn't want that he didn't
want that guys
so that's why he played the move b6
now what do i do now again i'm i'm
better here
but again it's he's got no weaknesses
it's very hard to win this position
because opponent has no weaknesses and
now
he actually wants to go here and then
knight c4 to completely equalize the
game
so i mean he just
so the example i go here he goes here
and then he's just trying to trade
tonight so i have to do something here
i have to do something here so i
decided to uh you know that this is a
critical moment
uh e5 i'm not a big fan of because then
you're giving this knight
wonderful squares like this and like
this
to go to okay so this squares
will be wonderful so
that's why i don't want to do that
let's think of a plum here guys uh
bishop g5 no we can't bishop g5 d4 is
hanging still
a5 i'm not sure guys he just takes
and then you can even put the knight on
b6 there so i'm not sure if
this is really gonna work
what do we do here
rook bd1 correct dio rook bd1 because we
want to try to play d5
absolutely absolutely we play now to
play d5
okay now he goes here
knight d6
activating and i play d5
and here my opponent i think panicked
and made a mistake that
should have cost him the game so in this
position his best
chance is to take to take on b5
and i have two options here i probably
have to take back with a b and we play
this position where you know
i think he has good drawing chances but
again i'm gonna play for a long time
because
my b-pawn is fixing this too i can try
to
advance a 4f5
well i don't have any other choice
because if i if i move the bishop
it's even worse now he attacks this way
okay i don't have a choice i have to
give up one of the bishops here
so but he probably didn't like this idea
that i take
d e and this is very very interesting
because now if it takes
i take and now knight is under attack
and if he tries to keep the knight
i have a check and we have the mate
rook f8 coming up and it's a mating
net okay
on h96 so
but here he has a very good move here
knight d4
and now if i take he takes back with the
rook
bishop takes take
and he has this idea so looks like
he's gonna have good drawing chances
here most likely this is gonna be a draw
okay
so
all right
so now
this was his main option he had to take
okay
he absolutely had to do that but instead
he played the move e5 it's a mistake
because now
i have a very strong pass pawn but he's
trying to get f5 in here
so here i played
the correct move rook a2 the reason this
is
important because he is threatening to
play f5
putting pressure on e4 and then player
4. so that's why i have to do something
so i have to move this guy
f5 bishop d3 now if it takes goes here i
go here
yeah now we're not scared because we
have a strong center
he plays here i played a5 correct and
now
a6 so now he's got two weaknesses
and i thought this was just perfect this
is just perfect here for me
look over king up
and here it was you know i had to be a
little bit more precise in my play
here i kind of shuffled around this
position is pretty much winning for me
here
i just have to just take and put the
bishop on c6
see i went i went around a little bit
here i should have just take
take and put the bishop here and this is
just the winning position
um and just convert i
i tried to shuffle around a little bit i
was hoping somehow to force him to play
a four or take take then f3
i wanted to win cleanly but it didn't
quite work because
he kept finding ideas like i went here
now i wanted to take but then he has
this so it was i couldn't
get exactly that position but now
i finally realized let me trade one pair
of rooks
which i accomplished doing that now i go
here
now i go rook here and now i was hoping
to get this bishop on c3
and then i will be annoying him with
this threat of
um f4 but he played a good move he went
here
so now if i go bishop c3 he will just
play bishop f6
so here i realized that it's time it's
time to do it and i played it correctly
the only problem is we're down to about
a minute each here now he took
i play bishop c6 correct and here
this is perfect everything is done
correctly i'm about to win the game guys
i'm about to win this game and qualify
to the world cup if it takes
i just take back with the king and i'm
just have two bishops
i have some rook b7 ideas
and some bishop c3 a7 is weak complete
domination
and here he plays quickly knight c4
and i have about a minute here
and i have about a minute here and here
i make a mistake that cost me
a win here white to play
can you please find the winning
continuation here
the way i played i still had some
chances but it was nowhere near
nowhere near
to what i could have had
white to play now what's the best move
here
to win this game
yeah bishop c3 is is the is is the
strongest
because i didn't see this i thought he
just takes but here
the problem with my play was even if i
didn't see the best move here i could
just take here
and i'm just winning here then i simply
go here
and here and i will win this game but
here i have an even better move here
guys look at this
attacking the knight knight has to go
away
let's say here i take hitting the rook
and now finishing him off now
look at this yep that that's game over
right there
yeah this was so precise this king d3
idea
and if he goes king knight d6
i just take and now he's completely
pinned he cannot move anything here guys
if he goes back here we're entering this
way
thank you adam thank you adam good night
yeah you saw the most important part
here
of the game now i take and again again
it's so close
this was a difficult peel to swallow
because it was
really well played game i thought you
know meticulously pressuring pressuring
meticulously
and getting this you know to the winning
position and then just
not making the the right decision
uh no i don't know that grandmaster uh
chudir i don't know
uh now rook b7 is another move i know
you guys suggested this is an excellent
move too
now if he takes we just take back
threatening to queen
if he goes here now this is the
important move i didn't see this move it
should be four
now if he takes we promote and if he
takes
we simply play again king d3 important
move
now the knight has to go and we simply
take on d6
if check just go here and the game is
over again
i mean yeah he he has to go back
and i take he can try to set up a little
blockade but it's just
i'm up upon i have two bishops this is
just over
[Music]
uh well he's attacking my bishop so this
knight c4 was a clever move by my
opponent
and i just i now i'm looking at it it's
just so clear to me i should just
play bishop c3 keep the bishop and then
rook in i mean
it's just so clear just to do this this
and it's just
game is over there is no way he can save
this game
there is no survival here whatsoever
uh instead i took and now
takes takes and here he had a very
strong move he actually made a mistake i
was still winning after this
but he here black has a very strong move
here
block has a strong move here guys
what is the idea here for black
well i played pawn takes pawn and this
was a mistake i should have just taken a
little bit more time here
i moved too quick here i didn't want to
get more into time trouble so i should
have just
taken my time but i took he took took
and now bishop d6 this is a
strong move incredibly strong move here
and he might be holding this position
because the problem is now i don't have
a way to activate my rook
if i go here then he's got this tactic
rook takes c6 hitting my bishop
and now if i go check he just goes roxy
takes bishop takes okay
so yeah bishop d6 is very strong
it's very very very very strong
and he would have had good chances so i
had more winning chances later
i'll show you but again this is not the
same now it's not
not so easy to win this position
i'm hoping to get a king on c5 and play
i need to be able to play this move d6
in order to win this
and here we are playing on 30 second
increment
and here he makes a mistake he makes my
life easy with this move
and what i gotta do is i gotta start
with i played rookie eight here but i
gotta start with rook d a check
he has to go here if he goes to e7 just
rookie a check
rookie six and i pick up e5 then i have
two connected puzz puns
and now i got rookie this is winning now
because e pawn is hanging
he takes now check he cannot come
forward because
of the rook d7 mate has to go here now
check
it's a little bit more complex i
understand but now we go here
and uh the problem for him is i have
a threat of just pushed deep on now and
also have a threat to put a king in here
and just
close the door and mate him with bishop
b5
so that's why this makes this position
completely hopeless too
okay but again it's not as same as
before so this was the second win i
missed
i had to start with the check and then
rookie then the game goes on
and we get to this position i'm still
trying to make progress but he was
defending
quite well and now he makes another
mistaking c7
and here is the third moment where i
have a win here
but it's a little bit more
computer-esque okay
so but since you know that there is a
win here i want you to spend a little
bit of time
and find the win this was my final win i
had in this game
uh after this it was more difficult
so why to play how could i have won this
game
now it's um
we need to see the problem is with king
c5 guys
he has this check and the problem is
with rook f6 he guarded so this bishop
is this bishop is very annoying and we
need to understand that we have to do
something
towards this bishop because if this
bishop is gone from g5
then we're going to be able to either
play king c5 or rook f6
yeah i did play king d3 but
unfortunately that wasn't the best
so it's a really nice idea here that we
can do
f4 absolutely guys f4
wins the game on the spot because now if
he takes with a pawn
then i go up here and now d6 is
devastating he doesn't have the bishop
e3 check
any longer okay
so he has to take back with the bishop
and now i go here
threatening d6 check
for king so he has to go here check
he goes here and now we start pushing
the rook cannot go anywhere says to go
here we're pushing now we want to queen
and now he goes here and here i have
two different ways to win one of my
ideas is to go here and here that wins
i mean he has to go here here
here then i take then i go back and then
this is winning but i have much nicer
way to finish this game here
much much nicer way i can finish this
game here guys
yeah f4 is fancy i agree but
again you need time to find a foreign
which unfortunately i didn't have
rook takes f
uh we'll take a look at that line
patrick that line is losing but
yeah we can take a look
uh so what's the finish here what's the
nice finish here guys
absolutely bruno yes yes bruno
and we push and look at that look at
that two connectors
going down and if he goes here he wants
to queen we just simply play king c5
simply controlling this and then pushing
our guys in
and the game is over this this would
have been again a beautiful way to
finish this tournament
uh there was a question about if he
plays
bishop takes what was the question
if it does this
ah about this yeah then then the problem
is this
patrick check check
and then check
and check winning the rook winning the
piece
uh and if you go backwards then then
let's just bet a7 is hanging you're
gonna lose
yeah and then i went here i shuffled
around
and here actually a mistake king d3 now
now he's getting
king is very strong on c5 i thought i i
thought he would crack finally somewhere
here but then he found a good move here
roxy
and check and the final mistake is check
i should just play rook e8
still advantage for me but now i just
didn't expect this move
because i thought i'd go here i go here
and i only looked i only looked at this
it was my bad because i thought now i'm
finally gonna start pushing my pawn
i thought i'm gonna start winning this
but i i completely forgot
this idea and this was an excellent
resource by my opponent
and now he's trying to get active and
here my clock was
ticking down and i i saw that if i
played this
my rook is getting trapped
i can't trade rooks it's going to be a
draw
so
if i take take if you're wondering about
this this doesn't work
unfortunately as bishop d6
i probably should have played like this
anyway but
that it's just a draw here
and if i try to keep my rook here and he
has this
hitting my rook goes back rook f7
and now things are getting really really
complicated
i mean it's equal now yeah i should have
played bishop c6 of course i should have
still played bishop c6
i mean uh the way i played it was just
the drill i took
and now i played bishop for a good move
hitting my rook
i go away and check and now i don't have
a way to escape i cannot even go here
because this is a mate
so i went here and the game
ended in a draw then we had this tie
breaks and then
another two games and armageddon which i
lost on time in a drawn position
because i had four minutes versus five
uh but uh yeah
i i should have yeah i'm when i should
have played bishop c6 i still
should have done this and because here
i mean i can at least
try you know i have to play this move
i can try at least you know uh
oh yeah the problem here is he plays
bishop f6 sorry i just realized he goes
here
and now i don't have d6 he has this and
winning this
but yeah
so
but maybe if i take bishop takes the
king comes to d6 as a dead troll
if i play a five again he just comes in
with the king
um yeah yeah just i can go here
you can just even take maybe
yeah uh yeah
so this was this was a tough tough tough
uh game guys
very very tough game and again again
this is much more complicated than it
should have it should never have been
this complicated to win this game
all i had to do is play the
natural move again you just keep things
simple here just bishop c3 it takes
and here i probably would have played
already king d3 because it's pretty
clear that knight moves i just take only
five
and everything is falling apart and if i
take
any or even if i take this is still a
technically very easy position
yeah i mean the end game yeah it was
tough i mean i thought it was a good
game i thought i played
relatively well this game and you know
on point with my plan and my thoughts
but just
unfortunately the result wasn't the one
that i needed it
to qualify so that was a pity
but anyway still uh you know glad to be
playing some chess after a year and a
half and
uh hopefully i'll do better in the next
tournaments okay
uh all right guys thank you very much
everybody for watching this
two games this lectures today i'll be
back
i'll be back again on next thursday so
i'm i'm working this week and next week
so you're going to see me more
and make sure you check out the twitch
as well
so you will see some of the streams on a
twitch and
i will have some more lectures for you
prepared there are a couple of more
games from this tournament
i would like to show you okay all right
well i hope you guys enjoyed this game
it was uh you know
definitely i definitely enjoy playing
the game the process everything about
this game was enjoyable for me except
the result
so but anyway hopefully for better
results next time for me
and thank you again everybody for
watching and
we'll see you again next week okay take
care bye bye everybody
you